Aozubillahi mina Shaytana Rajeem Bismillahir Rahmanir Raheem Alhamdulillahi Khalakil Wujudiminal Adam wa Ja'ilin Noori mina Zulam wa Mukhrijis Sabri minal Alam wa Mulkit Tawbati Alan Nadam Fanashkuruhu Alal Masa'ibi Kamanashkuruhu Alan Ni'am wa Nusalli Ala Rasulahil Akram lis Sharafil Asham wa Nooril Atam wa Kitabil Mahkam wa Kamalil Nabigina Wal Khatam
Sayyadi waladi adam aladi basharabihi qisabnumariyam wadda'alibi asatihi Ibrahimu alayhis salam hainaka na yarfa'u kawa'idabaytillahil muharram Fasallallahu alayhi wa alayhi wa salam wa ala adba'ahi khairal ummam aladi barakallahu bihim ka fatan nass al-arabamin hum wal ajam Wa salallahu ala amir al-mu'minin alanza al-batin waka'idil qur al-mahjalin
Ghalib Ala Kulla Ghalib wa Matluba Kulla Talib Alhamdulillah Aladi Anzala Ala Abdihil Kitab Walam Yaja Allahu Aiwaja Alhamdulillah Aladi Lam Ya Takhizwaladan Walam Ya Kunlahu Sharikun Filmulk Walam Ya Kunlahu Aliyum Mina Dhulli Wa Kabbir Hu Tagbira Alhamdulillah Hiladi Nahmaduhu Wanasta'inuhu Wanastaghfiruhu Wanu'minubihi Wanatawakkalu Alai
Wana 'udubillahi min shururi anfusinawa min sayyati 'amalina man yahdihillahu falamudillah la wa man yudlilhu falahadi Allah.
Wanashaduan la ilaha illallah wahdahula sharikala wanashadu anna Muhammadana Abdullahi wa rasuli arsalahullahu ta'ala bilhudawadin al-haq li yuzhirahu aladinikuli wa kafabillahi shahida
Allahum mala ilmalana ila ma alamtana inna qaantal alimul Hakeem.
Allahumma alimna bimayanfana wayanfana bima alamtana.
Allahumma inna na 'udubbikamin il min la yanfa wamin qalbin la yaksha wamin aainin la tadma wamin nafsin la tashpa.
Faam ma baadi akullu subhanahu wa taalafi kitabihil kareem, paada akulla audubillahimina shaytana regime bismillahir Rahmanir Rahim.
Rabbish Rahli Sadri, Wa Yasirli Amri, Wahlul al-Aqdatam mill Lisani, Yafqahu Qawli.
Allahum masabitna aindal moutibila ilaha illallah, wallahum majal namin Alladina amanu amila salihat, watawasahu bil haq, watawasahu bil Sabr, Amin ya Rabbil Alameen.
Assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi wabarakatu.
So as I mentioned today, I just wanted to end these sessions, Alhamdulillah, for the opportunity.
to be able to talk about our prophet.
And, you know, thank you all for joining and taking the time out.
I know we have such busy schedules, but may Allah reward you for making this a priority.
Today's session, like I said, is more geared towards my kids in the session.
I have my nephews, my nieces, and then I'm sure there are many other young adults in the group that I don't know of.
But I hope that this session will help you in some way and make things easy for you.
So I wanted to end this with a model of success.
The dictionary defines success as the accomplishment of an aim or a purpose.
So if we are all going on a bus and I invite you young boys and girls in this group,
to join me on that drive.
And let's say we drove by this beautiful mansion, right?
A stunningly beautiful house on top of a hill with this magnificent sports car outside and an incredible backyard with an Olympic size swimming pool in it.
And if I asked you guys, do you think the guy living in this mansion is successful?
Overwhelmingly, I think your answer is going to be the yeah, right?
So let's say we continue driving and a little further we see a man, a homeless man living in a cardboard box on the street.
And the clothes that he's wearing appears to be like a couple years old.
Now, if I asked you, is this man successful?
What would you say?
I'm pretty sure your answer will be
No.
And that's the problem.
The problem is in the way we think about success and the way in which we think about failure.
Now, when we turn to the Quran, we find that one of the most beautiful, one of the most captivating, magnificent palaces that were ever built was the Castle of Firaun.
It was one of the most amazing palaces ever built.
Was Firaun successful in the eyes of Allah?
No, he wasn't.
According to the Quran, he was amongst the worst of losers, the royal losers.
What was the second kind of person we met on our trip?
That homeless man, right?
Was Ibrahim kicked out of his house?
Yes.
Did Musa have to flee from his city and live a poor life in a foreign land?
Sure But were they both failures?
No Not according to the Quran according to the Quran they were both extremely successful people So when I see this world through the lens of Quran my perspective changes The Quran is teaching me that a homeless man is successful
And an incredibly wealthy man, an incredibly powerful man is a complete failure in the eyes of Allah .
This means success in the eyes of Allah has nothing to do with fame.
It has nothing to do with power, wealth.
It has nothing to do with how beautiful you look or how many likes you get on Facebook.
In the same way, failure from Allah's perspective has nothing to do with poverty or destitution.
So then what is success?
There are several words for success that are used in the Quran.
The most commonly used are fawz and falah.
Those are the two words that you must have come across quite often if you recite the Quran.
The word fawz it means victory.
Like when you win a competition or generally when there is some kind of prize involved, the word fawz is used.
wa man yuta Allah wa rasoolahu yudhkhilal jannatin tajarimin pahtihal anharu khalidina fiha wazalikal fawzul azeen Whoever obeys Allah and His Messenger is going to enter paradise that has rivers flowing under it.
They will live there forever.
That is a great victory.
So it creates this image, the word fawz, it creates this image like a prize, right?
Paradise is being given as a prize at the end of the journey.
But falaah
is a much more powerful word in Arabic.
It is actually an agricultural term.
The word means to till the ground, to plow the land, to cultivate it.
What do you do when you till the land?
Like a farmer, when he tills the land, what is he trying to do?
He unfolds and he reveals its intrinsic properties of growth.
When you till the land, you break open the surface of the earth and you activate its power of productivity.
That's imamate of Falah.
When a farmer works for months on his farm tilling the land, cultivating it, laying the seed, watering it, protecting it from insects over and over again, month after month, what happens eventually?
He gets a harvest.
which is many times more, exponentially more than his original investment.
That is Falah.
That's the concept of Falah.
That is success.
To receive a return on your investment that is beyond measure.
Now one of the motifs of Quran is the use of oaths.
Right?
Allah swears by things in the Quran.
We see this many verses in which he does that.
And the purpose behind these, and this is a very complex subject.
I'm just going to sort of browse over it, but it's very interesting why Allah takes oaths.
But to summarize, the purpose is that to grab our attention.
That's the first purpose.
And second, to emphasize the point that he's about to make.
And always, you know, oath is taken of sanctified things, right?
We take oaths of sanctified things, things that are important.
If I said, you know, I swear to you by this mosquito in my room or I swear to you by the stain on my carpet or this ripped t-shirt, you know, it's not going to generate serious confidence in you, is it?
About what I'm about to say.
But if I
swear by things that are valuable to me, right?
I swear by my daughter, I swear by the life of my son, then it increases confidence and it adds value to the reason and purpose of my taking that oath.
Now, what if Allah is the one taking the oath, right?
We understand its importance in the context of human beings, but now what if Allah is the one taking the oath?
How would that grab your attention?
And how much trust and importance would you place on what he's about to say?
And what if Allah swears not by one object, but multiple objects, multiple sanctified objects?
How would that affect you?
You see my point?
So Allah takes some oaths in Surah Al-Shams over some objects that are really important for human life.
Keep in mind the importance of an oath as you hear this.
Allah says, Wa shamsi wa duhaha, I swear
by the sun and its brilliance.
First oath, wal qamari idha talaha, and by the moon as it follows.
Second oath, wan nahari idha jallaha, and by the day as it brightens things.
Third oath, wal laili idha yakshaha, and by the night as it conceals things.
Fourth, was sama'i wa ma banaha, and the heavens and the one who built it.
Fifth,
and by the earth and the one who spread it.
Sixth, and by the soul and the one who perfected it.
Seventh, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala takes seven oaths using 14 objects, right?
The sun and its brilliance, the moon and its following the sun, the day and its luminance, the night and its concealment of things.
The heavens and the one who built it, the earth and the one who spread it, the soul and the one who perfected it.
Seven oaths using 14 objects of oath before coming to his point.
So whatever he's about to say, how important and valuable do you think it is going to be?
And what is it that he wants us to know?
He has revealed what is wrong and what is right.
So he makes this declarative statement, and then he comes to the point.
See that word?
Indeed, the one who purified himself succeeded.
That same word is used, exponential returns on investment.
And the one who corrupted himself has failed.
So successful is he who purified his soul during his lifetime, and the one who corrupted his soul is the ultimate failure.
So with that definition of success, I wanted to share with you these 10 qualities that were identified by a neuropsychologist who studied successful people over a period of several years.
And he found certain qualities that were common in them.
Now the principles of success, right?
If they're good for this world, this dunya, then they should also be good for the spiritual success to me, because that's what principle means to me, universal truths.
So I've been trying to follow some of these and I've seen some really tangible improvements in my life.
So I thought I'd share these with you, hoping and praying that they'll help you as well.
Again, this is just nasiha, it is just a suggestion, take it or leave it.
But at least give it a shot is what I would say because, you know, I've learned not to reject ideas without trying them first.
Anyway, so these qualities that he mentions, the first quality of success he says is that successful people have a strong sense of purpose.
In order to succeed, you have to have a strong sense of purpose.
What is our purpose as Muslims?
Our purpose
is our Lord.
He is our ultimate purpose.
It is the recognition and our willing submission to our Creator.
Wa ma khalaktal jinna wal insa illa li'abudoon We have not created jinn and man except for recognizing Allah Subhanahu wa ta'ala as the only one worthy of our devotion and worship.
La ilaha illallah That's our purpose.
And what greater sense of purpose than to know that our goal is Allah ?
What greater purpose than to emulate the beautiful character of our Prophet ?
And the essence of his character was humility.
That is the key to success in Islam.
Humility in our dealings with the Creator and humility in our dealings with his creation.
The second most identifiable character, he said, is that successful people seek out role models or mentors.
And these mentors instill in them a sense of possibility.
This is the reason why Rasulullah was given the stories of previous prophets, you know, those prophets that came before him, to give him tafbeeth, to make his heart firm.
So that he would know that he would have success just as the prophets before him had success despite all their tribulations.
So role model, having a right role model is extremely important for success.
Look who we follow today, right?
Look at our role models today.
Hollywood and Bollywood stars, singers, actors.
Our culture is filled with these icons.
These false idols that are set up for people to imitate.
Not great people, not people of high akhlaq, not people of great character.
Actors, musicians, mushawizin, people of the lowest level of human society in history.
If you study history,
Roman history, Greek history, any history in the old time, you'll see that the lowest people in any society have been actors and musicians, the jesters in the courts.
There's nothing noble about these professions.
And yet, in today's society, they are exalted, they are worshipped, and they're put up on this pedestal for us to follow.
You have the best example to follow in the character of your Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam.
What impresses you about these people?
Seriously, what impresses you about these actors that makes you wanna imitate them, be like them?
What is it?
Because they display these beautiful human qualities on a screen, on a movie of love, of courage, of charity, of generosity,
of patience, resilience in the face of adversity.
Is that what attracts you about them?
They were acting, just acting.
They could be wretched in their real lives and many of them are.
My prophet was not an actor.
My prophet was not pretending to have these beautiful qualities that capture the heart and mind.
He was living them daily.
he was the embodiment of every truth that has ever come to mankind and in following him we are elevated you know today the world is going insane over wanting to be like like someone right they want to be like because to them being is being like when you don't have an essence of your own
You know, like all these people out there imitating pop stars because they don't have a personality of their own.
They're empty people.
So they take the shells of other people because being for them is being like.
They have no reality of their own.
So Michael Jackson wears one glove, they start wearing one glove.
If Stallone starts wearing Ray-Ban glasses, they start wearing Ray-Ban glasses.
And this is a disease.
You know, we as Muslims, read the history.
We as Muslims used to be trendsetters.
People used to imitate us.
But look how we've fallen.
So you want a role model to follow?
I'll give you a role model.
His name is Muhammad Mustafa Sallallahu Ali walaihi wasallam.
Follow him.
Ali Ibn Abi Talib, another role model.
Not an actor, not a pretender, not just acting to be courageous.
So really take some time to think about who you want to follow and why.
I see this with real seriousness.
I mean, you guys are our future.
You are the future of our religion.
And we have high hopes from you.
Seriously, we have high hopes from I have high hopes from you.
So be the light in these dark times for those around you.
Be a role model for your friends by adopting the character of your Prophet , and you will find success in this life and the next.
Inshallah.
The third quality they say is the strength of visualizing goals.
No one had more clarity of his goal than our Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam.
You know, visualizing ourselves in the presence of Allah.
Visualizing ourselves in the presence of a Prophet, of Maulana Ali, of the Aimmah.
You know, visualizing that they are greeting us with happiness and pride and not with disappointment.
You guys have seen that Lord of the Rings, right?
There's that scene in that movie where that king falls in battle, I forget his name, and he's about to die.
And his daughter is crying next to him.
I remember he says to his daughter, don't be sad.
In that scene, he says to his daughter as he's dying, don't be sad.
I go to my father's in whose mighty company I shall now not feel ashamed.
What a powerful statement that is, right?
I go to my fathers in whose company I shall not feel ashamed.
SubhanAllah.
When I die, when I leave this world, that's what I want to be able to say to my daughter.
That's my vision.
That I'm going in the company of my prophet.
I'm going in the company of Malana Ali, the Imams, and I'm not ashamed.
I don't feel ashamed.
That is what we want inshallah.
So our vision is the vision of success.
We are people of success.
And this religion is a deen of success.
It is not a deen of failure.
And our prophet was the most successful human being that ever lived on the face of this earth.
The fourth he said is a positive sensitive orientation.
That we dwell on past successes and not on past failures.
That we never give up hope.
That we never stop striving no matter what challenges confront us.
And this is why Allah reminds us.
Remember your past successes when you were weak and Allah gave you victory in the battle of Badr.
And so we have to remember that Allah will give us victory in the end if we keep trying and if we don't give up.
You know, I'll tell you something about setting goals.
You know how everybody tells you when you hear this dream big, reach for the sun, the moon, the stars.
Don't.
If you want my sincere advice, don't reach for the sun.
Think small.
Don't think big.
Reach for the light bulb on your ceiling.
That's an awesome goal.
Because what happens is you get so excited and you take on this enormous burden, this entire weight of the Islamic practices in one day, and then you collapse under its weight.
Like going into a gym and trying to bench press 300 pounds on your first day.
That's crazy.
So my advice to you, find small, manageable goals.
That's what works for me.
If you're not praying at all today, start with one single prayer.
If you're praying once a day, try adding another one onto it.
Take on one quality of the profit you want to adopt and work on it for a while before you pick up another.
And then celebrate your success, seriously.
Enjoy your success.
Feel great about doing that one extra prayer today instead of beating yourself up about not doing three.
Seriously, I promise it'll work wonders for you.
And I might get into a lot of trouble for saying this, but the things I do for you guys.
You know, once the prophet was at a place and he wanted to set up a fire, he asked his companions to spread out and bring water.
No, actually he's told them to spread out and bring twigs and branches that they could find.
I think it's in Daim as well.
So they all went out and they picked up these small little things and they piled it on the ground.
And soon a huge pile was formed.
And he turned to his companions and he said, Look, this is how good deeds accumulate.
And this is also how bad deeds accumulate.
SubhanAllah.
So work on collecting these tiny twigs, tiny branches of good deeds, of good character.
One more prayer, one more fast, understanding one more verse of the Quran, one more act of courage, one more act of generosity, of temperance, one more small act of patience, not losing it, one more realization of gratitude,
Right?
And before you know it, you'll have this huge pile of good deeds in your collection, inshallah.
So that's another goal, that positive sensory orientation and a focus on it is important.
The fifth he says is self-assurance.
To know and believe that you can succeed.
Do not feel weak, do not grieve.
For you are great if you are believers, if you are believers.
So have the confidence and assurance that you will succeed in the end.
We have an everlasting life of joy and happiness ahead of us in Kuntum Mumineen if you are believers.
So study your religion, learn about it, because knowledge builds certainty.
Knowledge builds confidence.
It builds self-assurance.
Get your knowledge from your own studies not from what the media tells you.
Not from what your friends are tweeting about.
Take it from the source from the Quran.
The next he says is that successful people they plan and organize.
So start your day with a spiritual plan.
What are you going to do today?
How will you manifest the truth today?
Or how will you conceal it?
Are you going to follow Rasulullah today?
Or will you follow Iblees?
What will you prioritize today?
Is it going to be your salat or is it going to be fun and entertainment?
And once you've established that, work everything around it.
No, Rasulullah Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam, he did not spend his day in seclusion on the Musallah with the Tasbih in his hand all day long.
No, he was out there enjoying the gift of life.
But he knew what his priorities were.
So successful people know how to prioritize.
They break down their goals into workable, achievable parts.
So we have to look at the most important things in our lives and we have to take it, our Salat.
our Akhlaq, our Ibadah.
We have to learn to prioritize our day around these things and not the other way.
That if I have time, I will do Salat.
No, I will do my Salat and if I have time, I will do something else.
Our Deenul Islam, our debt of submission has to come first and foremost.
So get the essentials in.
Seriously, I know people arguing over ingredients in their toothpaste and not concerned about their daily prayers.
They get caught up in this, these trivial matters.
There's this show these days going on, right?
A friend of mine, right?
He watched, we were watching this show and I got up for prayers and I went and I came back.
He was still watching the show and he says, Wow, you know, my faith is renewed.
And all this and I said,
What kind of, you know, fresh Iman is this that you see me going getting up for prayers and it doesn't move you to pray.
But yeah, just taking all that nice feeling about, oh, how beautiful Islam is, but then not getting up to pray.
What kind of Iman is that?
Because that's the last I checked Iman is work.
Islam is hard work.
And they get caught up in these
You know, even like in these discussions, you get caught up in these trivial matters.
Get the essentials in before you worry about the trivial things.
Because this was the disease of that Talmudic rabbinical mind, which asked what kind of cow?
What color of cow?
Fat or thin?
Right?
In Surat Al-Baqarah?
And they say that
Devil is in the details, right?
Even in today's culture, we say that.
These are narrow-minded, simpleton people that spend their lives in trivial pursuits, in matters of no concern.
We have greater things to prioritize, like Salat, like fasting, like Zakat.
Our Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam was a universal man.
He raised us above these trivialities and he put us into the most important matters.
Yaumalayan faumalun wala banoon illa man atallahabi qalbin salim.
The day that nothing will benefit them, not wealth or anything except the one who comes with a sound heart, qalbin salim.
And so worry about where your heart is in your prayer, not where the feet is, not what color topi you're wearing.
Where's the heart?
Is it with God or is it with Amazon going over your shopping cart?
Or is it with Netflix wondering what's going to happen in the next episode?
You know, the other day somebody was telling me that people get upset with this person if she wishes them Juma Mubarak.
Amazing, right?
They don't get upset when they lie, when they cheat, when they gossip, betray people's trust.
No.
They get upset when someone wishes them Yaumul Juma.
Oh, you know, this is a bit...
This is an innovation.
I mean, seriously, you're going to get offended and upset for somebody wishing you the blessings of Friday.
And that's the big priority instead of worrying about the prayer of Friday.
Seriously, we've just gone mad.
You know, is it assalamu alaikum or is it salamu alaikum?
Oh my God.
Seriously, you know, should I put a space after the AL before I put the salam in?
I'll tell you what you can put there.
It's just, oh my God, I can't tell you how.
So, we have to learn to prioritize.
The only reason, you know, these big corporations are so successful is because they know how to plan and how to organize.
They plan way ahead of time.
We can't even plan for tomorrow, right?
The only thing some of us have become good at is just planning what we're going to eat for the next meal.
The next one he says is the ability to acquire the necessary skills needed to succeed.
And that means you have to identify where your weaknesses are.
And one of our greatest weakness is that we read the Quran, but we don't understand it.
I think that to me personally, I think that's one of the biggest problem.
How is it that as Muslims, we have not examined the Quran?
People taking pride over, you know, my son, my daughter is six months old and she completed like five Quran.
Like that's the biggest thing today with the recitation of Quran.
What about the understanding of Quran?
What about understanding the meaning behind Quran?
You know, so many of us have this romantic attachment to the Quran.
Oh, what a great book.
But we've never understood it.
We read it like a parrot, but we never take the time to understand it.
What's the point?
This is a book of guidance.
How do you get guidance from a book you don't even understand?
Right?
We're like people in this amazing restaurant looking at this menu written in Chinese.
How are we going to order?
When are we gonna be bothered to taste the beauty of Quran?
And this is why this romantic attachment to Islam is such a flimsy attachment.
It's an attachment that leads to extremism.
It's an attachment that leads to blind passion, right?
And passion, once you get passionate about something, then everybody knows passion is something that is incompatible with the intellect, right?
Like that story of that sparrow on top of Prophet Suleiman's place of worship.
So for those of you who don't know that, there was this sparrow.
He was trying to convince a female sparrow that he was a worthy mate.
And she wasn't paying any attention to him.
And this is a story, right?
He said, You know, if I wanted, I turn this dome right over on the head of Suleiman for you.
And Suleiman alayhis salamu knew the interpretation of birds, he called him down.
And so he comes down, you know, all shaking.
his little sparrow heart beating in his little sparrow chest and Sulaiman says, What made you say that ridiculous remark?
And the sparrow says, O Prophet of Allah, don't you know that lovers are never taken to account for what they say in the presence of their beloved?
In other words, I was in a state of passion.
You can't take me to account for that.
And this is the reality around us, right?
We get so these passionate displays of things and
We have absolutely no idea what we're doing, what we're reading.
It's just amazing.
So build your skillset, study the Quran, understand the Quran, study the meanings of the Dua, study the meanings of these supplications you say in your prayers, right?
There are resources available.
I mean, I did it.
I learned the whole Quran without, like most of it, I started off with my own self just by learning, you know,
Google.
And then I got went to teachers and I had, you know, found the proper resources and did that.
So can you.
But do it slowly.
Don't have to do the whole thing in one day, gradually.
And don't worry how long it takes.
Who cares?
You have your whole lives ahead of you, Mashallah.
So all I'm saying is get started.
Start collecting these small twigs, but do it consistently and before you know it,
you will be reciting with comprehension and gaining something from it.
The next quality is that they are patient people, he said.
They have .
Be patient and enjoying others to patience.
I'll tell you, there are two lessons as far as I'm concerned that we have to learn.
Because all of the tribulations coming to us are based on two things as far as I'm concerned.
One is kibr, arrogance and pride, and the other is lack of patience.
Arrogance and the lack of patience.
Until we get rid of this kibr, this sense of superiority from our hearts and recognize that it is humility, tawadr, that elevates us in the eyes of Allah.
Not arrogance and pride.
Unless we do that, we are never going to be successful as individuals.
We're never going to be successful as a community.
And we have to learn to be patient.
This disease of just no patience at all, instant gratification, it's destroying our spirituality.
Islam is nothing if not delayed gratification.
Our gratification is in the akhara, not in this dunya.
And we have to learn to persevere.
Wa an lay salil insani illa ma sa'ah No one has except what they endeavor for, what they persevere for.
Wa anna sayyahu saufayura Indeed, you will see the efforts of your endeavor.
On the Day of Judgment, Allah says, Innahada kaana lakum jazaan wa kaana sayyukum mashkura
This is the reward for you and your efforts have been shown gratitude by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
We want Allah's appreciation.
We don't want this world's praise.
What good is that?
How long is it going to last?
And if we follow the teachings of the Quran and if we follow the Sunnah of our prophet, we can have both.
Look at our prophet.
1400 years later, people are willing to die for his name.
SubhanAllah, that's Sayza.
That's glory, that's fame, that's respect.
Waban arad al akhirah wa sa'alaha saiyaha wa hua'umu'minun fa'ulaika kaanasayu hum mashkura whoever desires the hereafter strives for it, right?
putting in the required work, he is a believer.
Kaanasayu hum mashkura his efforts will be appreciated, they will be thanked and rewarded by God.
So that's the other one, you know, work on removing arrogance from your hearts and developing patience 'cause you guys, you don't even let anybody say anything to you before you just explode.
So just take a chill pill, right?
Relax.
Then the last thing he said is the ability to love what one is doing.
You have to love what you're doing.
They love Allah and Allah loves them.
They're pleased with Allah and Allah is pleased with them.
And none of us truly believe until we love Allah and his messenger more than we love our own selves.
And so working for Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and his messenger sallallahu alaihi wasallam should be the most beloved thing to us.
So this is the last quality you have to love what you are doing.
This is not a forced religion.
Ours is not a forced religion.
There is no compulsion in religion.
There is no force in religion.
Ours is a religion of love.
It is a religion of willing submission, not forced submission.
And this is why I said earlier that this religion begins with a choice.
I mean, you have to decide if Islam is for you or not.
And if it is,
then you have to make a conscious choice to accept it and then enjoy it.
You have to love your Islam.
If you're doing it, if you're following Islam with a resentment and a frustration or out of fear of getting burned in hellfire, there's something very wrong with your understanding of this beautiful religion, I swear.
I can honestly tell you, I love my Islam and I'm not a hermit.
I'm as much out there living and enjoying life as the next person.
I love hiking.
I keep going on trips all year long.
But I try to prioritize my essentials.
Every day I try to work on my character, adopt something good, leave something bad.
And I fail more often than I succeed.
Honestly, I fail more often than I succeed.
So what?
I try to celebrate what I did succeed in.
And I try harder to work on what I failed at the next day.
And thank God, I have friends who keep reminding me when I struggle.
Those are the key kinds of people you want in your life.
People who lift you up when you're down.
Not those who want you to stay small.
There are many people who want you to stay small.
There's Marianne Williamson, right?
I've talked about her before also.
Love her.
In her book, she has this quote which is just incredible.
There's a book Return to Love that she wrote and she says in that our deepest fear is not that we are inadequate.
Our deepest fear is that we are powerful beyond measure.
It is our light, not our darkness that frightens us most.
We ask ourselves, who am I to be brilliant?
Who am I to be gorgeous, talented or fabulous?
Actually, who are you not to be?
You are a child of God.
Your playing small does not serve the world.
There's nothing enlightened about shrinking so that other people won't feel insecure around you.
We were born to make manifest the glory of God that is within us.
It's not just in some of us.
It's in everyone.
And as we let our own light shine, we unconsciously give other people the permission to do the same.
As we are liberated from our own fear, our presence automatically liberates others.
What a beautiful description of what a, like, I love this quote from this lady.
So yeah, that is our, you know, don't stay small, you are.
You know, you are manifesting the glory of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, this Khalifa on this earth.
Don't sell yourself short.
So these are the qualities that he mentioned about success.
And you know, it all begins with waking up from our state of acedia, the spiritual laziness that I talked about earlier, because Islam is work.
Anything that is valuable beneficial worth pursuing in your life.
Tell me one thing that does not require work.
Why would Islam be any different?
But we are in the state of ghafla this heedlessness like drowned in it There's a verse in the Quran Allah says We have prepared for the hellfire multitudes from the jinn
and human beings and he says what has made you know and I'm saying this that what has made these people eligible for hellfire he describes that he says Lahum qulubun la yaf qahuna biha they have hearts and they have intellects but they do not use them they don't use their intellects to reflect on what's really good for them Walahum ayunun la yubsiruna biha they have eyes but they don't see the true realities with it Walahum adhanun
They have ears, but they don't listen to the words of guidance.
Then he says, These people are like dumb beasts.
They are like cattle and sheep.
But then Allah says, He says no.
And this no here is rhetorical.
In Arabic, Bal is used to clarify something.
So if you made a mistake or said something that was not clear enough, you use the word bal to re-emphasize.
So Allah is saying these heedless people are like animals.
But let me clarify further.
They are much worse than animals.
Why?
Because they are in a state of heedlessness.
Now if you look at the animal kingdom,
you will not find animals in a state of heedlessness.
Animals, no matter what they are doing, they are always in a state of awareness.
If you watch a dog eat or a rabbit eat, right?
Rabbits, right?
They're constantly moving their ears around.
Why?
Because they're worried.
They're constantly worried about these external threats, external dangers.
Watch a mouse come out of its hole.
It doesn't just sonder out of its hole.
It comes out slow.
It moves its head around, right?
Checks out the surroundings.
To me, that is Taqwa.
Seriously, you wanna learn Taqwa?
Watch a mouse come out of its hole.
That's God consciousness.
That's how we need to be, that level of awareness of God.
We can learn a lot from animals, right?
That's why Allah uses them as metaphors in the Quran.
Look at the lizard.
Ever seen a lizard come out of its hole?
It's constantly looking back and forth, right?
Right and left.
The Arabs say more bewildered than a lizard.
Because if you look at a lizard, it's just constantly moving its head because it like it's bewildered.
But what is it really doing?
It's checking.
Is there danger out there?
It's thinking.
Animals are constantly aware of danger.
Why?
Because if they're not constantly aware, their existence is threatened.
They realize that if they are in a state of heedlessness, they are endangering themselves.
And this is why Allah says these people are like animals.
In fact, they are more astray than animals because animals are not in a state of heedlessness about the danger that is threatening them.
But we human beings, constant state of heedlessness about our spiritual survival.
We don't care.
Seriously.
Animals, if they sense fire, they run.
What do we do?
We call each other up.
Hey, there's this huge fire there.
Let's go check it out.
Right?
Taking selfies in front of the fire.
I'm not making this up, right?
This happens or not.
Because it's all fun.
It's all entertaining.
Everything.
We're drowned in fun and entertainment.
Everything is a joke.
Everything is a fun.
The world is fun.
The Akhara is fun.
And we're not realizing that we are dying spiritually.
We are dying.
People, your oppression is only harming you.
It's killing you.
We have to change.
I mean, how much selfishness can go on?
I want you kids to grow up in a world that facilitates your humanity.
I want a world for you that doesn't destroy your humanity or take it away from you.
I want a world that does not deprive you of this
quality, right?
It's your birthright.
It's your birthright to become a human being, to not operate at the level of animals.
It's your birthright to become real people.
Not to become junk people that spend their lives in these trivialized malls buying all this junk crap to fill their junk life.
When are we going to wake up?
When
When are we going to respond to the call of Allah and His messenger?
Ya yohalladeena amanu astajeebu lillahi walir rasuli iza da'akum lima yuhlikum.
O you who believe, answer Allah and His messenger when they call you to the path that will give you life.
iza da'akum lima yuhlikum.
when they call you to that which gives you life that will make you feel alive when are we going to answer that call when are we going to respond to that call of Allah and His messenger to something that will bring us to life and the implication in that ayah is that as long as we do not respond to that call we're dead people literally we are dead people our hearts are dead our lives are dead
Our society is a society of death.
We live in a society that celebrates the death of the spirit in giving life, in giving life to the lowest pursuits of humanity.
This is the death of the soul because the soul can only be brought back to life by recognizing what it was created for.
For recognizing what its purpose is and then setting out and striving to achieve that goal.
Recognizing that we will have shortcomings.
That we will make mistakes.
That those mistakes are part of our humanity.
That Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala knows those mistakes.
So he will forgive us when we turn to him.
That is why we were created.
We were created to respond to our Abu Diya.
our servitude to Allah Subhanahu wa Ta'ala and the only way the only way a slave feels its wudiya its servanthood is in its abject nature that if we do wrong we desire the atonement so that we can reconnect with our true nature this is why we were given the gift of wudu this is why we were given the gift of salat what beautiful gifts
What a beautiful gift to purify ourselves five times a day and stand before our Lord desiring atonement for our sins and for strength for our future actions.
What a gift.
We are just wasting away the preciousness of our lives.
I mean, you have one short life to do something, to do something great, to be great people, one short span.
Look what people are doing to relieve the stress around them to just to relieve this this empty meaningless life just to taste this one moment to have an adrenaline rush to feel alive.
That's all they're trying to do.
They're trying to feel alive because they're dead.
They are dead people.
and by jumping off a bridge with a rubber string attached to them and seeing this pavement this cement pavement come towards them heading right for it suddenly this person feels for one moment that he's actually alive and then he wants to repeat that experience because he wants to feel alive that is not the life human beings were created for
It's not through adrenaline rushes.
It's not through the rush of drugs penetrating your brain.
It's not through the rush of cocaine.
It's not through alcohol numbing your mind.
It's not through the rush of jumping out of an airplane or skydiving.
Those are not the things that will make you feel alive.
The only thing that will make you feel alive is becoming a slave of the Alhai.
by becoming slaves of the ever living who never dies.
And this is our challenge.
This is the challenge of human beings and this is what we have to wake up to.
I'm going to end this today's session with the hadith from our Prophet sallallahu alaihi wa sallam.
And you know and this is
This whole conversation, everything I've said so far is for you guys, you kids, you young adults, which I keep saying because, you know, the elders already know all of this.
But this I thought was something which might really help you.
I hope and pray that it helps you.
There's a Hadith of our Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam, he said, Islam began as a stranger and there shall come a time when it becomes estranged again, just the way it began.
Islam began as a stranger and towards the end of the time it will become a stranger again.
Strange here does not mean weird.
Strange does not mean something out of this world.
It means that the society we live in, the society that you live in is going to find Islam and its followers strange.
Why?
Because Islam began at a time when people were chasing and worshipping their desires, their appetites.
They were worshipping multiple gods.
Might was right.
The rich were honored and the poor were abased.
Evil was strong and good was weak.
That's how Islam began.
Today, we see that we've come full circle.
The world is once again worshipping their desires.
The world is once again in submission to the gods of money, god of fame, the god of power, the god of stature, the god of looks, of pride, vanity.
Might is once again right, evil is once again ruling the world, and righteousness is once again weak and on its knees.
Bada al-Islamu ghariban wasayaudu ghariban kama bada'a.
Islam began as a stranger, and towards the end of time, it will become a stranger again.
But then he said, Tooba lil guraba'a.
There is immense good tidings for the estranged.
When you are strange, you act in ways
that are very different from what everybody else around you is doing.
That's what makes you strange.
When you wake up in the night to worship Allah, when the world around you is sound asleep, you are strange.
When you speak about pleasing Allah and making him your objective in life,
When the world is making fun of religion and mocking God, you are strange.
When Allah and His Prophet is your sole objective, because Allah said, O Messenger of Allah, tell them that indeed Allah should be their ultimate objective.
So when you have made Allah as your objective in a world that has the fulfillment of their desire as their primary objective, you are strange.
When you dress modestly in a world that celebrates nudity, you are strange.
When you refuse to smoke, to drink, to do drugs, when the rest of the world is celebrating and glorifying these things, you are strange.
when you help a needy with your charity in a world that is hoarding wealth, you are strange.
When you are saving yourself from marriage, when the entire world is celebrating fornication, you are strange.
When you respect your parents, when you respect your elders, your teachers, when the entire world is finding it so cool
to disrespect them, to make fun of them, you are strange.
When you honor Allah's gifts of food and drink, when you conserve natural resources while the world is busy wasting and destroying them, you are strange.
When you stay humble in a world that celebrates arrogance, that celebrates pride, vanity, you are strange.
When you take out time to recite and study and understand the Quran and you make time to learn about your prophet while the rest of this world is drowned in chasing the world or endless hours of mindless Netflix and Prime Video, you are strange.
And my Prophet SallAllahu Alaihi Wasallam said, Tooba yil 'uraba.
There is glad tidings, good tidings for the estranged.
So my advice to you is better be a stranger in this temporary life than a stranger with Allah and His Messenger on the Day of Judgment.
We do not want to be people on that day that says, Ya wailana, mambasana mimmarqadina.
Woe be unto us.
Shame be unto us.
Why have we been raised from our graves?
I wish we were never raised from our graves.
We don't want to be that people.
We don't want to be the people who say, Ya wailana haza yawmuddin Woe to us! This is the day of judgment that we had been warned about and we never paid attention to it.
We don't want to say to our Lord, Fayaqulurabbi laula akhartani qiza ajalin qaribin
Master, if you send us back in the world, we promise we will believe in everything that you said, and we will become righteous.
No, we want to be people who are greeted and welcomed by Allah and His Prophet in the afterlife.
We want to be people that they say, Yaa ayatu han nafsulmutuma inna.
Irji ay ila rabbi kya rabi yatam mardiya.
Oh my beautiful and content soul, return to your master in a state that you are pleased with your Lord and he is pleased with you.
Enter the company of my beloved slaves, enter my paradise.
(Alhamdulillahi Rabbil Alam, you salatu wassalamu ala rasuli he said na Muhammad al khatim na bin masid al masaleen mulahi wa wasi al bishrat al-waseen)